I used to do oil pulley, but I've gotten out of the habit.
So my rule is oil pulley.
That's what you swash, coconut oil or olive oil
in your mouth for 10 to 15 minutes
so that you spit it out of the sink.
Help pull toxins out of your mouth, out of your gums.
It can be very beneficial, but you do not do oil pulley
if you have any mercury fillings in your mouth.
That's an absolute no-no.
So if you have any mercury fillings,
any silver fillings you're about,
you do not do oil pulley.
That could make you worse, systemically worse.
Oh, I don't have any mercury fillings per cent.
Well, then you could go back to doing oil pulley.
There's nothing wrong with that.
Should it be a good systematically as well,
systemically, I think, as well as to where in my throat?
It can be good to do oil pulley
as long as you don't have any silver fillings.
What kind of oil?
Oil wellness has oil designed for health,
has a new oil pulley oil that you can use,
but you could use coconut oil.
You could use olive oil.
It's a really no secret to what oil you use.
Typically coconut oil or olive oil is what you would use.